our journey was finally coming to its
end we had set out to discover the
wonders of the sea but instead we were
greeted her only by hellish nightmares I
know now the sea cannot be tamed that
night we would experience its final acts
of cruelty most of the men were below
deck in their beds blissfully unaware of
the horrors we had awoken creatures you
wouldn't believe existed but worst of
all was the Kraken
[Music]
there is this misconception that the
Kraken is a beast that originates from
Greek mythology but why well shiny liam
neeson pretending to be Zeus obviously
doesn't help in this case to say the
ancient Greeks enjoyed sailing around is
a colossal understatement so naturally
they would have many stories of monsters
at sea the works of Homer helped to
popularize creatures such as Scylla and
Charybdis but neither one of these
really resembles a Kraken the most
terrifying of all these creatures was
Cetus a giant fish whale shark sea
monster thing it doesn't really have a
set appearance that we can easily
identify its best known as the sea
monster Perseus defeated when saving
Andromeda the confusion thing comes when
both the original Clash of the Titans
and the 2010 remake refer to this
creature as the Kraken in neither of
these movies does it resemble what we
would expect a Kraken to be so why not
just use the original name from a
mythological standpoint it doesn't
really make any sense but if you're in
Hollywood's position and you have this
giant sea monster from Greek myth that
the average person doesn't really know
by name then why not just call it a
Kraken more people will have heard of
the name and it's going to generate more
excitement also the phrase release the
Kraken is infinitely cooler than release
the CSIs because it sounds too much like
foetus but maybe that's just me so if
the Kraken isn't from Greek mythology
then where do these stories originate
from the stories of the Kraken originate
from Scandinavian folklore in the early
12th century the first written account
of the beast was in 1180 from Spada
Sigurdsson who would later become the
king of norway in 1180 for Sigurdsson
believed a monster in the shape of a
giant squid stalk the waters around
Norway Iceland and Greenland it
terrorized sailors who crossed its path
dragging them into the depths of the
ocean destroying their ships and making
their journey the voyage from hell
mentions of the Kraken can be found once
again around 1250 in a Norwegian texts
known as the King's mirror here the
narrator discusses all sorts of
creatures found in Ireland Iceland and
Greenland including mermaids and mermen
and of course the Kraken although at
this stage it was referred to as the
half gopher it's described as a large
fish or whale that resembles an island
more so than a living creature the
narrator comes to the conclusion that it
must be infertile otherwise there would
be hundreds of them at sea a creature of
the same name is mentioned again towards
the end of the 13th century in the
Icelandic saga which details the journey
of the hero or devour order as he
travels through the Greenland sea on his
journey he encounters two enormous
monsters the world's largest whale and
then the world's largest sea creature
the half gopher a monster so big that it
could swallow an entire ship feed on an
animal as large as a whale and create a
whirlpool by merely rotating its body
the term Kraken was first used by the
Danish Norwegian author Erik pontoppidan
when he argued that the Kraken along
with mermaids and sea serpents actually
existed in his works the natural history
of Norway published in 1752 and 1753 he
believed it to be a great tentacled
monster that would surface and attack
ships at sea and then subsequently
caused well
polls when returning to the seabed
several authors and zoologists discussed
creatures similar to the Kraken before
pontoppidan but he was seen as the real
driving force behind stories of the
Kraken because of the translation we
don't really know if it was meant to be
a squid or an octopus some also thought
these stories are inspired by the
Leviathan a sea monster mentioned in the
Hebrew Bible but that's a discussion for
another time up until the end of the
18th century the Kraken and its
appearance remained fairly ambiguous it
went by several different names and the
only constant was its enormous size the
start of the 19th century is when the
Kraken was thrust into mainstream
popular culture and this is when the
giant squid or octopus liked appearance
became the norm it would also be
mentioned in countless works of fiction
and still is even to this day some of
the most famous pieces include the
Kraken a sonnet by Alfred Tennyson he
describes the Kraken as sleeping in the
depths of the ocean so deep that no
human could ever possibly know when it
eventually awakes from its ancient
slumber both man and Angel will witness
only death and destruction Tennyson
published in this work in 1830 obviously
predates Lovecraft
and the popularization of cosmic horror
but there is an uncanny resemblance
between Tennyson's Kraken and
Lovecraft's Cthulhu both are enormous
creatures that slumber the bottom of the
ocean waitin for the day they wake to
destroy everything we think we know what
really connects both these stories and
much of the fictional work surrounding
the Kraken is the fear of the unknown we
as humans even to this day like to think
that we know almost everything there is
to know about the earth which is why we
look to other planets and start to
explore the truth is that the ocean is
the one place on earth that we've barely
explored and at the time these tales are
created we knew next to nothing
all throughout history whenever we are
unable to explain something we make up
stories based on what we can see so is
it possible that someone just saw a
giant squid and thought it may have been
months
yes it's entirely likely that's how the
story started in the first place the
giant and colossal squid are types of
squid that actually do exist they may
not grow to the size of a Kraken but
they are still pretty big the colossal
squid can grow as big as thirty three
feet in length and weigh up to 700
kilograms but most of them are found in
these stomach's of sperm whales the
giant squid can grow bigger in the size
but an overall mass is considered
smaller than the colossal squid that
however doesn't mean it's easy food for
a sperm whale its tentacles aligned with
hundreds of teeth that can do some
serious damage when we examine sperm
whales it's pretty common to find scars
from their encounters of giant squid
there is still so much about these
species of squid that we don't know to
put that into perspective the amount of
giant squid we've studied and measured
is only about 600 which as a sample size
doesn't give us anything definitive
there may be squid or other creatures
out there even bigger the famous French
writer Jules Verne mentions a group of
giant squid in his novel 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea
which was published in 1870 you can see
Captain Nemo in the crew of the Nautilus
struggle against these giant squid in
the 1954 film version which had a lot of
its marketing geared towards promote in
the giant kraken like creature both the
1916 silent film and the 1954 version
made sure their movie posters and
promotional art showed us the giant
squid and i guess that's an insight into
our obsession of the kraken and
creatures that lurk in the depths of the
ocean perhaps the most famous piece of
literature to feature something that
resembles a Kraken is Herman Melville's
novel the whale or more commonly known
as Moby Dick chapter 59 is titled squid
the crew mistake had Giants SPECT had
figure four the whale but instead it's a
giant squid they go on to explain that
the giant squid are found at the very
bottom of the ocean and server's not
much more than food for sperm whales
when these sperm whales are under duress
or being pursued
would disgorge or throw up the food in
their stomach which is why these giant
live squid float to the surface the
chapter ends of the narrator discussing
rumors of the great kraken mentioned by
pontoppidan potentially taken the form
of a giant squid the works of Alfred
Tennyson and Co inspired several 20th
century authors from HP Lovecraft to
John Wyndham and the idea of this
slumbering monster the bottom of the
ocean is one that several authors
attempted to adapt in terms of movies
and television it's only become more
popular if you have something that's
loosely based at sea or even just has
some kind of water in it then why not
just throw in a Kraken Clash of the
Titans release the Kraken Pirates of the
Caribbean
throw in a Kraken Davy Jones Kraken face
House of Greyjoy Kraken King Kong Yami
Kraken Hotel Transylvania 3 clearly what
this movie needed was a giant singing
kraken voice by one of the Jonas
Brothers Spectre I don't really have a
joke for this one it just left me
confused as to whether someone in the
cinema had swapped out James Bond for
some hentai but sadly that wasn't the
case and the people in charge don't this
would be a good idea moving swiftly on
our giant squid / octopus friend also
appears in countless video games it's
crazy how many games I've played that
have a crack and as some kind of boss or
just the random monster that you kill
but what's even crazier is the amount of
games I've played where there is no
Kraken at least in terms of a giant
monster instead there's a mission a
symbol a character or even in the item
named after the Kraken and I guess I
never really thought about how common it
was until making this video it's
honestly really weird how it's
everywhere the idea of the Kraken has
become so common it appears outside of
fiction as a way to market products to
the general public
you have crack and spice run Razer
Kraken head says the Kraken
roller-coaster and even Old Spice had a
scent named Kraken guard so I guess the
idea of the Kraken just excites some
people
despite how much of our planet we've
explored the deep sea is still a mystery
to us the fact that we truly don't know
what lurks at the bottom of the ocean is
what makes tales of the Kraken and other
sea monsters so compelling as much as we
would love to rule out the possibility
of their existence there may be monsters
at the bottom of the sea and one day we
may just wake them from their slumber
and that my friends is truly terrifying
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
I've seen this seven times and I still
don't understand what is happening and
why why are there tentacles here why are
these naked women being caressed by baby
Krakens I don't understand what is that
I don't what is that
you
you